In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for August 3 on which we commemorate, Saint Salome, the
Merber who died in peace.
The wife of Zebedee and mother of the Holy Apostles James and John, Salome, whose name
means peace, was a kin's woman of the most holy Mother of God.
She followed the Lord throughout his preaching ministry.
One day, while she was still ignorant of the true sense of the Lord's mission and
believing that he had come to inaugurate an earthly kingdom, she asked him to give her
sons places of honor.
Christ set her right and reminded her that those who wished to share in his glory must
first drink the chalice of his passion.
Showing greater courage than the disciples who had forsaken the Lord, Salome was present
at a distance at his crucifixion, together with the Mother of God, Saint Mary Magdalene and
another Mary.
And once the Sabbath had passed, she went and bought spices to embalm the body.
When the holy women questioned among themselves who could help them roll away the heavy stone
that closed the tomb, they discovered that it was open.
Going inside, they saw a white clad angel who proclaimed to them the good tidings of the
resurrection.
Nothing, and beside themselves, they fled, saying nothing to anyone until the moment when
Saint Mary Magdalene returned alone to the tomb and saw the risen Lord himself.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.